If RPC has to be a viable mechanism for
structuring operating
systems services above the kernel,
using the client server paradigm.
Then it is important to
reduce this overhead.
Now let's see how we can
reduce the overheads.
And make RPC cheap enough that
you want to use it in building
client service systems.
How do we remove these overheads?
The trick is to optimize
the common keys.
Now what are the common keys?
Well, the common keys is the actual
calls that are being made by the client
to the server.
We expect that those calls
are going to be made several times
during the lifetime of the server and
the client.
And so that's the key thing.
That you want to make sure
that during the actual calls,
the copying overhead
that I talked about.
And the locality of the arguments and
the results, in terms of stuff being in
the caches that are accessible to the
client and the server, that's the key.
That's the common key.
That's what we want to make
as efficient as possible.
Now, setting up the relationship between
the client and the server itself,
on the very first call by the client,
that needs to be done exactly once.
And that process is
what is called binding.
Binding the client and server.
That is done once, the first call
is when the binding happens, and
that's done once.
Now, since the setup for the binding is
done only once, it's a one-time cost.
It's okay if it is more
expensive than the actual costs.
So, the binding, we can afford
to make it more time consuming,
it's okay to do that.
And these ideas should sound very
familiar to you from exokernal,
that we've discussed before,
that we want to make the one time costs,
not focus on the one
time cost of setting up.
Which is a one time cost, but
focus on it is a recurring cost,
which is the actual calls
that are being made.
So now, let's discuss in more
detail how this binding works.
The server has an entry
point procedure called
foo that it wants to make it
available for clients to call.
And in order to make it available for
everybody,
it publishes this entry point
procedure in a name server.
And let's the kernel know that there's
an entry point procedure called
foo that's available for it.
And the name server is a vehicle by
which anyone in the system can find on.
It's sort of like the yellow pages,
right?
So, you want to look
up somebody's name or
phone number,
you look it up in the yellow pages.
Similarly, this name server
serves the same purpose
that if I want to know what
services are offered as a client.
If I want to know what services
are offered by a particular server,
I can find out from the nameserver
what are the entry point
services available from S.
So foo is an entry point service
that's available in the server,
registers the name server, and
let's the kernel know that it
has this particular entry point.
And at this point the server
is basically waiting for
bind requests to come from the colonel.
Now the client looks
up the name server and
finds that S is an entry
point called foo.
So this is an entry point
that's available for
this client to make
a call on the server.
So the client issues this call s.foo,
meaning that it wants to execute
this procedure foo onto server S.
And so that's RPC call,
the first time, C is making.
And this of course results
in a trap into the kernel.
The kernel doesn't know whether
the server is willing to
accept calls from the client or not.
And therefore what it has to do is,
it has to check with the server whether
there's a legitimate bona-fide client
that can make calls on those
entry point procedure foo.
And so the kernel basically makes an
up-call into the server saying that hey,
you know what?
There is this client that wants to
make something with this identity.
Wants to make a call on your
entry point procedure foo.
And that's the up call
that goes into the server.
The server, if it recognizes
that this client is a bonafide
client that can make this call,
it grants permission via the kernel that
this client can make this call on
its entry point procedure foo.
So once this validation has been done,
what the kernel does
is to set up a descriptor called
the procedure descriptor.
And the procedure descriptor is a data
structure that is in the kernel.
And it is for this particular
entry point procedure foo.
And it's part of granting
access to the client
to make this call into its
entry point procedure, foo.
What the server is going to
do is tell the kernel
that these are the characteristics of
this particular entry point procedure.
In particular, it's going to say,
this is the entry point address where
you have to call me if there is call.
This is the address of the entry
point procedure in my address space
where code exists for
this particular procedure foo.
And this is indicating the size
of an argument stack, and
I'm going to talk to you a little
bit more about this in a minute.
And this argument stack is going to
be the communication area between
the client and the server, and this
entry in the procedure descriptor is
just seeing, what are the sizes
of this argument stack?
So this communication vehicle
that is going to be established
between the client and
the server is going to be dependent at
the formal parameters that are being
passed the client and the server.
And the results that are being passed
from the server back to the client.
Based on that, the server is going
to indicate to the kernel that
communication area that
I want is this size.
So, that's the size of this A-stack.
I'm going to talk more
about that in a minute.
And it is also going to say
how many simultaneous calls
S is willing to accept for
this particular procedure foo.
And the purpose of this is,
if this is a multi-processor and
there are multiple cores and
multiple processes available.
Then it may be possible for
S to farm out multiple threads to
execute simultaneous calls that
are coming in from multiple
clients distributed in the system.
And so
they're saying how many concurrent calls
the server is willing to accept on
behalf of this particular procedure.
So, this procedure
descriptor is specific.
Do this procedure foo, and it is saying,
where is the entry point in the server's
domain for this particular procedure?
What are the size of the communication
buffer that is needed to be established
by the kernel for communication
between the client and the server?
And the third thing is,
how many simultaneous calls
the server is willing to accept for
this particular procedure, foo.